en este vídeo aprenderemos sobre los
circuitos eléctricos y la ley de ohm la
cual es una ley fundamental y básica de
los circuitos esta ley reúne los
conceptos de voltaje del cual hablaremos
más adelante la corriente que
representamos con la letra y mayúscula
para evitar confusiones con la letra c
mayúscula que se refiere a colom y la
resistencia que relaciona a los dos
conceptos anteriores y que denotamos con
la letra r mayúscula la relación
matemática de estos tres conceptos es
muy sencilla el voltaje es igual a la
corriente por la resistencia otra forma
de verlo es la siguiente si dividimos
ambos lados entre la resistencia nos
queda que la corriente es igual al
voltaje entre la resistencia pero de una
forma intuitiva que es el voltaje que es
la corriente y que es la resistencia y
cuáles son sus unidades para que todo
esto tenga sentido para nosotros para
comprender estos conceptos
intuitivamente vamos a usar una analogía
de circuito dibujando una tubería de
agua no es una analogía perfecta pero a
mí me parece muy útil para
comprender estos conceptos imaginemos
que tenemos una tubería llena de agua y
que está cerrada en el fondo el agua que
está en la tubería tiene cierta energía
potencial y esta energía potencial es
análoga al voltaje pues es potencial
eléctrico pero no es solamente potencial
eléctrico es potencial eléctrico por
unidad de carga son jules que son
unidades de energía potencial por q lo
que es la unidad de carga aunque las
unidades en general del voltaje son
volts ahora imaginemos qué pasa si
destapamos esta tubería pues el agua va
a caer inmediatamente la energía
potencial se convierte de manera
inmediata en energía cinética podemos
fijarnos en una parte en particular de
la tubería y preguntarnos cuánta agua
pasa o fluye por aquí por unidad de
tiempo la cantidad de agua que pasa por
este punto en la tubería durante cierta
cantidad de tiempo es análoga a la
corriente eléctrica la corriente es la
cantidad de carga por unidad de tiempo
que representa la carga y 'the el tiempo
intuitivamente podríamos decir que es
qué tanta carga pasa por un punto de un
circuito en un segundo
también podemos verlo como cool oms por
segundo
la resistencia podemos imaginarla como
algo que impide que la carga fluya a una
tasa arbitrariamente alta regresando a
la metáfora de las tuberías de agua
agregamos algo que impida que el agua
fluya por ejemplo una sección estrecha
en la tubería esta sección estrecha es
análoga a la resistencia de forma
similar a la metáfora anterior
destapamos la parte inferior del tubo en
la parte de arriba seguimos teniendo
energía potencial lo que es similar al
voltaje que se convierte en energía
cinética cuando el agua comienza a fluir
por la tubería pero ahora en cada parte
de la tubería la cantidad de agua que
fluye por ella por unidad de tiempo va a
ser menor pues tenemos literalmente un
cuello de botella aquí esto es análogo a
una resistencia cuanto flujo de carga se
impide la unidad de la resistencia s lo
que se denota con la letra griega o mega
ya que definimos estos conceptos usando
una metáfora veamos un circuito
eléctrico primero dibujamos una batería
la convención es que la terminal
negativa de la batería se indica con la
línea más corta y la terminal positiva
con una línea más larga esta batería
genera un voltaje es un voltaje de 16
volts a través de esta batería podemos
decir que la energía potencial por colom
es de 16 volts recuerden que tenemos
electrones en la terminal negativa de la
batería si existe una ruta posible estos
electrones seguirán esa ruta para llegar
a la terminal positiva de la batería
vamos a proporcionar una ruta pero aún
no dejaremos que los electrones pasen
por ella ponemos una abertura aquí y
mientras el circuito esté abierto los
electrones no podrán pasar esto es
análogo a la parte cerrada de la tubería
pero si cerramos el circuito entonces
los electrones ya tendrán una ruta
disponible para llegar a la terminal
positiva de la batería lo que es análogo
a cuando destapamos la tubería y el agua
comienza a fluir por ella cuando tenemos
un diagrama de circuito así indica que
en este circuito no hay resistencia al
menos en teoría en la realidad cualquier
cable o alambre por siempre
siempre tendrá una pequeña resistencia
gráficamente indicamos una resistencia
con una línea en zigzag esta resistencia
es de 8 oms la pregunta ahora es con
este voltaje y con esta resistencia cual
es la corriente que pasa por este
circuito cuál es la tasa a la que fluye
la corriente por un punto de este
circuito pausa en el vídeo y traten de
calcularlo para responder a esta
pregunta tenemos que usar la ley de ohm
despejamos la corriente y sustituimos
los valores del voltaje y la resistencia
la corriente es igual al voltaje que es
16 volts entre la resistencia que es de
8 oms esto es 16 entre 8 que es igual a
2 la unidad de la corriente es carga
entre unidad de tiempo podríamos decir 2
colomos por segundo o también podemos
decir que son 2 amperes y denotamos
amperes con la letra a mayúscula
hablamos de que los electrones fluyen
por el circuito y tendremos el
equivalente a 2 culos de electrones
fluyendo por el circuito cada segundo
esto se cumple para todos los puntos en
el círculo
de la misma forma que se cumple en la
metáfora de la tubería de agua aún
cuando es más ancha en esta parte y más
angosta en esta otra debido a este
cuello de botella la cantidad de agua
que fluye por esta parte del tubo por
segundo es la misma cantidad de agua que
fluye por esta parte angosta cada
segundo es por eso que para este
circuito sencillo la corriente que
medimos en este punto en este punto y en
este otro punto será la misma pero hay
un detalle aquí pausa en el vídeo y
piensen en la dirección en la que fluye
la corriente si saben cómo se comportan
los electrones se pueden imaginar que
los electrones viajan en esta dirección
así que podríamos decir que la corriente
tiene esta dirección pero resulta que la
convención que usamos tiene la dirección
opuesta esto tiene una razón histórica
cuando benjamín franklin estudiaba
circuitos por primera vez no sabía nada
sobre los electrones que se descubrieron
aproximadamente 150 años después lo
único que él sabía era que lo que la
etiqueta va como carga fluía entre estas
terminales
eran opuestas las etiquetó
arbitrariamente como positiva y negativa
en sus estudios sobre la corriente él
vio que la corriente fluía de la
terminal positiva a la terminal negativa
y seguimos usando esa convención en la
actualidad aunque es la dirección
opuesta a la del flujo real de los
electrones aunque más adelante veremos
que la corriente no siempre involucra a
los electrones así pues esta corriente
es de 2 amperes nos vemos en otro vídeo